the children are singing a song about
heading off to plant mangroves
but
ha
they have a day off school these
children from pangandaran are here to
work but first they sing some more I
love it singing puts you in such a good
mood when we get to work the children
and I will be full of energy and joy
solid angle Mira the tide is in so just
the top leaves that the young mangrove
plants are above the water the children
are here to measure how much the plants
have grown since their last visit and to
collect other data on the environment
they come once a month to check on the
progress of the mangrove reforestation
project yadi yada yada yada Latin the
old man grows were destroyed by a
tsunami in 2006 hi mom I want to do
something for the environment we live on
the coast and I feel it's our duty to
get involved and to protect it link 1
plus he's hitting me oh my god that is
why I bring my children here so that
they learn at an early age to love
nature and their surroundings the
project is organized by an NGO that
promotes ecotourism called in decon and
it's supervised by the united nations
world tourism organization the german
government has provided 1.2 million
euros in funding for this and other
projects in the region through its
international climate initiative
nearby a mangrove nursery has been set
up 35 thousand plants have been grown so
far and planted in an area that had been
stripped bare oh my boy yeah the good
thing about the mangroves we are growing
is that they have lots of roots ah
you're brought up in a convo I'm using
it they provide shelter for all kinds of
animals fish crabs and shrimp the
mangroves provide shelter so that they
don't get eaten mangroves also protect
human habitats they can significantly
reduce the impact of powerful waves
tsunamis are an enduring threat here
pangandaran is a beach resort just a few
kilometers away once again the town is
able to live off tourism
a tsunami in 2006 caused massive damage
to the town and the entire region along
the coast on the walls of the lifeguards
hut are photos of the aftermath almost
600 people were killed here
most of the hotels have now been rebuilt
it takes longer to restore the natural
surroundings the mangroves are just part
of that another is the coral reefs that
three metered tsunami triggered by a
major earthquake broke up the reefs and
swept them away
even before the tsunami the coral is
suffering a lot from many activities
like illegal fishing or also taking
stepping but after the tsunami the
situation is even worse our survey
showed that the coverage at that time is
only about ten percent of the coral but
new reefs can be cultivated concrete
beams have been laid on the seafloor
transplants of coral are anchored in the
small holes and they're growing after
five years or so this is what they
should look like and where there is
coral there are fish fish stocks are
recovering the diver is pleased with
what he found he said that the coral
grows very good as expected mostly they
grow one angelucci meters in the last
five months so we are quite happy with
that when the fish stocks are restored
the fishermen benefit to
sorry I didn't know about that yeah mm
since the tsunami they have to go much
further out to sea to catch enough fish
there's plenty of demand from the
resort's many restaurants it's going to
take years until a mangroves and the
coral reefs are back completely but the
beauty of the place can make you think
that pangandaran is well on the road to
recovery